yeah oh please thank you thank you ma'am
uh just the tea that I had asked for a
half an hour ago I'm okay thank you very
sweet
what a sweet surprise Selena Gomez shots
only murders in the building's fans
revealing Meryl Streep's part of season
three something her co-star Steve Martin
and Martin Short joked about during
their season two press run I would
imagine people are just like lining up
to come and do this show right I know
DiCaprio wanted to do it but I didn't I
felt there was a conflict with my
character okay and
um Meryl you know
sorry maybe next season yeah well now
that season three is in the making
Merrell being part of the cast is a
reality on Tuesday Selena shared a
teaser on Instagram sitting alongside
her main co-stars in the living room set
of the hit Hulu series hey guys we're on
set hey what are we shooting oh hi there
season three the gang is back hello yay
in the video cell shows cast mates
Andrea Martin and Paul Rudd and Rudd he
said to have a large role this time
around following his cameo in the season
2 finale could this honestly get any
better oh wait
but well I do think it could get a
little bit better drum roll
Steve do you want a pillow yeah oh
please thank you thank you ma'am party
anything you need uh just the tea that I
had asked for a half an hour ago I'm
okay thank you very sweet
Selena what was it like for
forget the call to work with these
Legends and what are you walking away
from uh from this experience with I had
a great time as you can tell I could
barely keep a straight face just hanging
out with them it was so wonderful and I
learned so much being around them
they're Legends in their own right but
they've you know they're good people
humble funny kind and professional and
it was just the best Steve Martin also
showed his excitement for Meryl Streep
joining the cast he shared a sweet snap
on Twitter with the caption quote the
filming of season three of only murders
in the building has begun a cast to
dream of it's really very very cool
Stephen Merrill are reuniting on screen
following their roles and it's
complicated I haven't had fun in almost
three years Jake they must be hammered
hey there's your ex-husband I had a
great time to be feeling groovy oh Jane
and last August an executive producer of
the Hulu murder mystery teased out the
Celeb cast seems to attract stars like
Meryl all I will say is that uh
the doors open up to you when you have
Steve Martin Marty Short and Selena
Gomez in your television show and if
they make a couple of telephone calls
for you so
um that's been our that's been our North
Star and our lucky star since we started
it and it continues to work for us
[Music]